okay so uh I'm a San Diego comic-con I'm
actually in the hotel room right now and
Marvel announced the Eternals for 2821 I
theus they're releasing seven movies in
2021
that's kind of bonkers uh but in this
video I want to talk about the Eternals
right because like that's that's kind of
like the big movie that they're
releasing that I think involves one of
them or one of the more obscure
characters it may change he's definitely
up there Shh he's just the master of
kung fu
right so like think Danny ran but Asian
and cooler but the Eternals are actually
the really really interesting title that
they released right I mean Doctor
Strange um into the multiverse of
madness whatever it is it's just gonna
be him it's gonna be like a like a
short-form defenders team basically with
like Scarlet Witch that's really what
it's gonna turn out to be at least the
1990s Doctor Strange defenders team when
he had like I'm like it was it was a
team composed of like like a rotating
roster and they would just go into the
multiverse and just do things but the
Eternals are a lot cooler so I feel like
a lot of people out there right now or
confuse about them like what are the
Eternals and what's the whole basis
behind them and why is everybody excited
what does this have to do with the x-men
okay so in the 1970s as most of you guys
know you had like Jack Kirby right like
Jack Kirby was the artist Stan Lee was
the writer and between the two of them
they created or brought back some of the
most iconic characters in the history of
Marvel Comics eventually Jack Kirby felt
like he wasn't getting his credit so he
left he went to DC and he created
something called the Fourth World
what's the Fourth World well that was
supposed to be a standalone series of
stories like the forever people things
like that didn't have anything to do
with anything
um and then he felt like he was getting
screwed over at DC so he left in the
middle of it all and then went back to
Marvel the fourth world introduced
things like the anti-life equation
Darkseid Steppenwolf things like that
that's where all that stuff came from DC
eventually just rolled it over into
everything else because what else could
they do but because of the fact that he
couldn't do the fourth world in DC he
created the Eternals and Marvel and what
he said was that or at least the way the
story one went down was that the
Eternals were a byproduct of the same
process that created the mutants in
Marvel Comics right so at some point in
the early days of man and not really
even to superly days but like thirty
thousand years ago thirty five thousand
years ago
see you you had a group called The
Wanderers and the Wanderers were
essentially the missing link between ape
and modern man right and so the the
sentience of Earth which is a woman
named Gaia who's also the biological
mother of four um she gathered two
Wanderers together and then presented
them to the Celestials and the reason
why is because the Celestials were
cosmic scientists they would travel
across the universe and perform
experiments different things like that
the idea was to show up on earth and
then conduct an experiment by modifying
the genes of early man into three
separate groups the first group was the
Eternals and they were really more
angelic like in terms of their
appearance right I mean for the most
part they had like perfect skin and they
could fly and they had all these
different attributes basically your
normal run-of-the-mill powers like
Superman except they can also manipulate
cosmic energy and then you had the
deviants who were more akin to like
trolls different things like that and
then you had what we're call just the
baseline humans right like their genes
were modified but the the results of
these modifications wouldn't really
start to show up until around 20,000
years later around actually I probably
say around 25,000 years later and 10,000
BC when you've got a Selene and then
eventually you get the the villain
apocalypse and then you get like Gabriel
Shepherd and the proto mutants and
things like that and that runs all the
way up to the modern day when you get
like mainline mutants the other reason
that that that Jack Kirby did this was
because this modification of the genes
of early man was also an explanation for
why it was that one like Bruce Banner
for example was blasted with gamma rays
he didn't just turned like this giant
massive tumors like you did in in Marvel
ruins instead he became the Incredible
Hulk right so it's kind of like these
genes were modified in such a way to
where they would lend themselves to
superhuman powers as opposed to just
turning humans and the crazy-looking
things and stuff like that anyway
sticking with the Eternals what you
ended up having was the eternal deviant
war and the way this played out was that
the deviants saw themselves as kind of
like the rightful rulers of the world
and to a degree they were for a long
time the deviants ruled a surface world
back before Atlantis sunk and different
things like that they ruled the surface
world and and what this did is is it
allowed the the Eternals to kind of
remain disconnected right so they just
kind of remain in the mountain is the
different things like that and didn't
really care about what went on with
humanity the results of this is that
eventually the Celestials come back and
what's called the second host right the
first host was them first showing up and
modifying genes
rivals whatever you want to call it it's
called a host it's like whenever they
show up it was called the second host
and the deviants were to attack this and
the result was that the the Celestials
initiated what was called the great
Cataclysm and this is what led to the
the sinking of Atlantis and what led to
most of the deviance being totally
obliterated and wiped out those who were
left basically took refuge underground
and they've been living underground
ever since the eternal saw what went on
and they were like this is wild sly they
started having more of a hand and in the
the goings-on of humanity not a whole
lot but some of them actually end up
leaving earth right and some of them
settled on Saturn's moon Titan which is
where Thanos comes from and so because
of that the Eternals on earth are for
the most part kind of disconnected for
everything because that's the question
people are gonna ask people are gonna
ask if the Eternals have been here the
entire time like some thirty thousand
years and they had these crazy powers
right like Icarus is the current leader
and he's got the ability to create that
you know mind we're just kind of
blending all the powers of the Eternals
together and creating some super being
if he could have done all these things
and he could have basically like stopped
Thanos right because if the if the
Eternals had summoned the UNAM on and
they had had him face-off against Thanos
he would have obliterated the ball right
I mean it would it would have been it
would have been no small feat like it
would have just been like okay so like
and he's done though and that would have
been it um oh wave through the hand so
to speak people gonna ask if that was
the case then why didn't why didn't the
Eternals do anything why haven't we seen
them before because it won't care
because they're disconnected from
humanity I mean you're talking about
beings that are almost designed to be
perfect and have incredible power why
would they care about what goes on with
what amounts to ants on anthills and
some other part of the world and does it
really matter then the same thing with
the Inhumans the Inhumans are
disconnected they're isolated that
removed from everything it's the way
their way the characters were designed
to be that being said I think two things
will come out of the Eternals movie the
first thing is that it'll set the stage
for the mutant population this is how we
get x-men into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe this is where mutants come from
right it's better than doing the whole
thing in like one film right like the
x-men movie comes out and it's like once
upon a time there were you Turtles and
they did some things and that we have
mutants it would it would be it'd be way
too much to cram into a single film so
it makes sense to kind of lay the
groundwork for where we're gonna get
with you know we're gonna get with the
mutants and and so on and so forth by
throwing it in the Eternals film and
then just kind of let it build from
there right I mean
if there's anything the Marvel Cinematic
Universe has established over the years
is that we as fans in the in the general
movie audience like this slow bill we
like to believe that what we're seeing
is gonna lead up to something bigger
even if they're cutting back from like
the 10-year long sagas and they're
focusing more on like three four or five
year long events still it's a great way
to set the stage for everything and I
kind of explained why we even have see
we have superheroes in the first place
and whether or not all just like
irradiated masses of tumors and and [ __ ]
like that the second thing is I think
it'll explain a backstory to Thanos and
it could actually even be used to
explain to kind of expand the the the
lineage of Bannos as a character to
Stannis has a brother his name is is
eros right I mean it's like depending on
on what comics you read sometimes you
refer to as starfox so that's actually
the name he had for a while when he
fought alongside the Avengers ah but it
could introduce things like Drax to
Destroyers daughter moon dragon there's
a lot of things that you could get from
from the Eternals film kind of building
up and sitting this age for a lot of
stuff so in reality this I think would
be one of those movies it's kind of like
a historical film right like the movies
done is throw it in there and then
suddenly we get this foundation for like
a litany of things that that show up
later on and and really in the MCU it'll
be the first time they've done something
like this to create a movie in such a
way to worse design not necessarily to
present a whole complex plot in and of
itself but to actually lay the
groundwork for a lot of the things that
are coming layer and turn on movie form
um having said that I think a lot of you
guys will look at the Eternals and and
depending on how they're done you will
see them as very much being analogues to
Superman and in a lot of different ways
and the reason for that is because
Superman's powers are pretty basic right
I mean like his powers are timeless
because Superman's timeless but the
powers and the powers of flight flight
and SuperSpeed and and you know
different things like that
super-strength that's pretty normal yeah
that's like max max landis set in his
video on the death and return of
Superman comic book companies just give
those powers out like candy right like
that's your baseline power you know from
there starts going into things like
reality warping and cosmic awareness and
and you know just how strong you really
are or something along those lines but
at the end of the day I think the
Eternals will be a building fill it'll
be a film design for the purpose of just
building up the MC
so oh no either way it'll be interesting
but I figured I would kind of throw this
out there and make people aware of
what's going on at least what to expect
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end and I
will catch you all later
[Music]
[Music]